so I just press space or do I have to
have that thing on there is it aluminum
or aluminium because I wouldn't know
what to call my aluminum model hi it's a
great model and you should call it
aluminium aluminum used to be the
American name but a few years ago I
can't remember 10 15 perhaps 20 years
ago there was an agreement that the
Americans would call aluminium aluminium
and the Europeans would change the names
of some of their elements
how many periodic tables do you own how
many periodic table ties do you have I
have no idea how many periodic tables I
own I've got two cups with periodic
tables and in my office I've got lots
and lots of periodic tables fridge
magnets mouse mats umbrella as regards
ties I suppose I've got about six or
seven on several occasions I've been at
a conference or somewhere like that and
somebody's admired my tie and I've just
taken it off and given to them so I've
owned a lot more ties than I've got now
where did most of the elements names
come from
I think the names of elements came from
all sorts of places there are some names
which are really old elements like gold
were known from prehistoric times and so
the names for gold are very different in
different languages or in in in French
and gold in English and so litter in
Russian so they're all sound quite
different because each tribal nation had
its own name and then in more recent
times there was a whole clash of
elements that were invented discovered
in the 18th 19th century early 19th
we're again different countries had very
different names nitrogen is called
nitrogen in English stitched off in
German and is called Azote in in French
so they're very different names but then
the more recent elements that have been
discovered are named by the person who
discovers them and sometimes for quite
random reasons sometimes they were
discovered in the place like dumb
starchy and more dubbing um sometimes
because people were really proud of a
scientist like Boreum or einsteinium and
sometimes like the most recent one
Kapernick him that was named after
Copernicus I think just because the
discoverers wanted to celebrate science
and this year is the year of astronomy
what do you think will be the names for
elements 112 through 116 and 118 do you
think they're ever gonna make an element
named after you
well I tried to guess the name of
element 112 planck um-- and I completely
got it wrong
it was Capponi seeum though I'm still
going for Copernican as being easier to
say I have no idea what the other names
will be because people named elements
after scientists who've inspired them
and how do I know what is going on in
the heads of those people who discovered
them and it's not just one because
nowadays these written very heavy
elements are named by hell discovered by
a huge team so you don't know which of
them is going to think of the name and I
don't know I'm sure nobody's they're
going to name an element after me and
I'm particularly keen that they
shouldn't because I have to be dead for
20 years before they can do it and I
don't want to be dead yet and what's the
hardest element for you to say why are
you asking that because I can't say bang
man
negative Maggie I think the hardest
element says number 111 which is rent a
gingham which may be fine in German but
I find it difficult to say in English
and some of the element names are quite
difficult to say in in English when
you're on the front of a class and as a
teacher or a professor you're bit
nervous
I had the chemistry teacher who said
elephants instead of elements in one of
his classes and he could never control
the class after that what first got you
interested in science I'm not quite sure
why we got interested in science my
first school where I was until the age
of 13 they didn't teach science at all
you weren't allowed to do it so I
suppose that was quite exciting that it
was it wasn't forbidden but nobody
taught you and so I used to read books
about science and I have a well I used
to have a chain I now got to Train like
this but I used to have a smaller one
and I did experiments when I was meant
to be doing my homework it was a
boarding school you lived there and so
we had supervise homework sessions and I
was doing experiments and with pendulums
trying to measure how quickly they did
and with the stopwatch
I borrowed a stopwatch from somebody so
I could measure it was one second and so
on and the teacher came up was very
angry and said why aren't you doing your
work and I had to tell him I was doing
science and I really liked physics but I
found the maths a bit hard but when I
was young I had a very good memory and I
was fascinated by chemistry and I could
remember all sorts of facts and I really
loved the colours of what happened in
the reactions so I suppose I really fell
in love with chemistry when I was a
teenager 14 15 16
and I'm still in love tell me about this
chain tell me about that you and you and
change because people probably don't
know anything about this
well you I always fiddled with my hands
when I speak I talk waved my hands and a
lot of the time I just play with things
and when I was a teenager I broke the
chain on my parents bath and I saw I
went to shop and built another one and
then when I got home I discovered I
could repair the original chain so I
kept the when I bought just as a toy and
I have ever since this is actually the
third one I've had since I was a
teenager and I just keep it in my pocket
and play with it I sometimes use it for
lecture demonstrations so spinning it
around and demonstrating angular
momentum which is one of the things I
have to teach our first-year students
but you can't take these things on
planes because they think it might be a
weapon so I have a plastic chain which I
take on aeroplanes